we really have to be careful in the
winds today i can't tell you how cold it
is outside
and you won't know until you step out
but i'm sure you've been hearing those
winds overnight
i want to get you your forecast for
those winds and let's just check on
nate's trash can
and how it's going to stand up to these
winds oh yeah
it's going to blow over nate bite your
trash can today we're looking at gusts
25 to 30 plus miles an hour today
and really i don't think the winds are
going to let up until we get into the
evening hours so
everybody help nate find his trash can
we're looking at lots of 40s around the
valley this morning but it
feels like the 30s there is a big wind
chill because of these winds out there
and we're going to keep them as i said
most of the day
wind advisories have been expanded to
western clark county
nye lincoln and esmeralda counties and
over into inyo county
including death valley today so it's an
area of low pressure that's moving
past us and it will shift offshore
working against that high that's already
up north off the coast of san francisco
and that's really going to keep the
winds cranking today
some showers are trying to kind of work
their way back up towards trump right
now
and a few very light returns up around
the moapa valley so
here's the forecast partly cloudy skies
a slight
chance of some showers around the area
today i don't think there's a big chance
for las vegas i mean if we see some
sprinkles at best i think that's
going to be about it but today's one of
those days we can't rule anything out
uh definitely cooler and windy upper 50s
did you see that pigeon or seagull just
fly by
i promise it just flew by okay 60s for
the rest of the week and then another
stronger system actually two for the
weekend
might bring us some showers and mountain
snow better chances saturday sunday
into monday all right let's